things that you are worrying about while
they're valid they're ultimately
irrelevant like like you know what I
mean like yeah like we're like we're
I've had a lot a lot of people die and
most horrifically in my life whether it
be through suicide drug overdoses you
know I had a lot my birth father died
when I was super young my my uncle who
was a big part of raising me my thing is
that we're gonna die and in a hundred
years from now No One's Gonna really
know much right you know it's gonna
happen and we're stressing about things
that the anxiety comes from a lot of
these things and this pressures that we
put on ourselves or that I could say I
was putting on myself and the truth is
if you look into any type of really
great literature like Albert Camus
absurdism and you study stoicism and
Marcus Aurelius and like all these
different deep rabbit holes go listen to
like 17 hours of Alan Watts you're gonna
understand that it's just it's kind of
pointless right like you can't control
the world I can't control the world all
I can do is control myself